bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
les questions cribles consacrée à la
pollution de l'air des millions de
français vivent dans un air pollué trop
polluée au coeur du problème 12 millions
de véhicules diesel trop anciens qui
sont dans le parc automobile français et
producteur de particules fines est
encore ce qu'a confirmé aujourd'hui
l'ademe l'agencé de l'environnement et
de la maîtrise de l'énergie une nouvelle
qui intervient alors que le gouvernement
réfléchit à une prime à la conversion
pour verdir le parc automobile tout de
suite direction l'hémicycle
la séance et reprises mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions cribles thématiques
poser à monsieur jean marie le guen
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement sur la pollution de
l'air thème choisi par le groupe
écologiste je rappelle que l'auteur de
la question et le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
merci de vous y tenir une réplique d'une
durée d'une minute et demie peut être
présenté par l'auteur de la question ou
par un membre de son groupe
pour la première question la parole et à
aline archimbaud pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues ma question
concerne la lutte contre les particules
fines émises par le trafic routier le
caractère cancérigène des gaz
d'échappement des moteurs diesel ne fait
désormais plus débat reconnu depuis 2012
responsable de façon certaine des
cancers du poumon par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé il provoque
également asthme troubles respiratoires
infarctus et accidents vasculaires
cérébraux soutenu par mon groupe j'ai
déposé au sénat une proposition de loi à
ce sujet qui suit un travail de
concertation et d'amendements
consisterait à intégrer dans l'actuel
système de bonus malus qui s'applique
d'ores et déjà au co2 pour lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique
un deuxième critère concernant la
pollution de l'air particules fines et
oxyde de carbone le fameux knox le bonus
malus est en effet un dispositif
équilibré à la fois incitatif et
dissuasif les sommes versées pour le
malus permettant de verser des bonus
c'est à dire des primes incitatives aux
consommateurs choisissant d'acheter des
véhicules neufs moins polluants et ce
dispositif est soutenue par les
associations mobilisées sur le sujet
monsieur le ministre les économies
réalisées grâce au diesel pour les
particuliers sont un mythe le poids de
cette technologie sur nos finances
publiques sur notre balance commerciale
et sur la santé de nos concitoyens et en
partie des plus précaires qui n'ont
d'autre choix par exemple que d'habiter
le long des principaux axes routiers
c'est en revanche une réalité il est
urgent de cesser de dilapider des
milliards d'euros dans une technologie
mortelle alors que nous pouvons à la
fois protéger la santé transformer les
emplois du diesel au profit d'une
économie innovante porteuses d'emploi
d'avenir et faire des économies
formidable à nos finances publiques en
redressant notre balance commerciale
monsieur le ministre ma question sera
simple et direct sachant que ce
dispositif a été redéposé sous forme
d'amendement à l'occasion du collectif
budgétaire
ma question est donc simple et direct
pouvons nous compter sur votre soutien
je vous remercie merci monsieur
jean marie le guen
merci madame la députée de votre
question vous avez raison de poser cette
question parce que c'est une grave
question de santé publique
d'abord et c'est aussi disons le d
éléments qui concourent à
l'environnement dans nos villes et puis
également aux capacités que nous aurons
à saisir ces questions qui sont une
difficulté pour nos concitoyens du fait
que beaucoup d'entre eux ont été incités
pendant des années et des années à
choisir la motorisation diesel et que la
raison nous demande de changer deux
motorisations même si je sais et vous
savez comme moi que les nouveaux moteurs
diesel sont sans doute beaucoup moins
polluant y compris en termes de
particules que ce qui
existait il y a un certain nombre
d'années
je sais qu'il ya des contestations sur
ce sujet il appartiendra d'ailleurs au
motoriste de d'éclairer les choses pour
savoir si à froid à chaud après beaucoup
de d'éléments de circulation on a
toujours les mêmes peu d'émissions
faibles émissions de particules en tout
état de cause il est parfaitement
légitime de s'attaquer à ce sujet en
ayant à coeur évidemment de tendre la
main et de faciliter cette transition
énergétique de nos concitoyens mais je
crois comme vous que cela peut être
effectivement une occasion très grande
pour notre pays pour notre industrie de
profiter de cette nécessaire mutation et
il faut donc que les conditions soient
réunies pour que nous aidions
nos concitoyens à opérer cette
transition étant entendu et vous en
serez d'accord avec moi que en zone
urbaine dense les choses ne se pose pas
de la même façon qu'elles se posent dans
les zones rurales et donc dans les
circulations jaillir intra rural d'un
point à un autre de la ruralité nous ne
sommes pas du tout dans la même
situation que dans les zones urbaines
denses donc je sais que et vous me
l'avez insisté votre groupe a proposé au
sénat et à l'assemblée un certain nombre
de modifications
sur touchant à la fiscalité du diesel
j'étais hier soir à l'assemblée
nationale pour débattre du budget jean
conclu monsieur le président j'étais
hier soir pour débattre du budget à
l'assemblée nationale et je peux vous
dire que nous avons marqué notre intérêt
lors de la prochaine loi de finances
pour faire évoluer notre fiscalité
diesel dans le sens que vous le
souhaitez peut-être pas sûr tous ces
aspects mais en tout cas pour avancer
dans cette direction merci pour la
réplique la barre le talent est là
mais ce le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je tiens
tout d'abord à souligner que je m'étonne
de l'absence de la ministre de
l'environnement du ministre de la santé
des transports et de l'économie qui sont
touchés au premier chef sur cette
question de la problématique de la
pollution de l'air ça c'est ma première
remarque ma deuxième remarque je suis
également interloqué par votre réponse
monsieur le ministre
quittant vous êtes dans la droite lignée
la même logique des anciens
gouvernements et cela depuis 30 ans qui
traite avec une certaine désinvolture le
problème de la pollution de l'air qui
est un vrai problème de santé publique
et qui n'a pas eu assez et est pris en
compte par les différents gouvernements
successifs laissez moi me vous dire
monsieur monsieur le ministre que je
comprends pour le coup le fait que
certaines ong au était contrainte de
porter plainte pour des problématiques
liées à la pollution de l'air contenu de
l'inaction du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre vous voulez du
concret en voici alors entre 42 et 50
mille morts prématurées chaque année en
france en raison de la pollution de
l'air explosion des risques d'infarctus
d'avc d'infections respiratoires et même
de cancers des voies aériennes des
centaines d'hospitalisations pour des
problèmes cardiaques et respiratoires
pour l'économie il ya un coût à vue dans
un jeu une minute pour poser pas deux
minutes six cent cinquante mille
journées d'arrêt de travail par an du
fait de la pollution de l'air et enfin
la pollution de l'air grave l'économie
française de près de 50 milliards
d'euros monsieur le ministre la santé
serait elle devenue une simple variable
d'ajustement dans le cadre
merci merci la parole est à raymond vall
pour le groupe rdse merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le groupe des reçus auquel
j'appartiens est très attentive à la
question de la pollution atmosphérique
vous le savez selon très récent rapport
de l' ocde puis de trois millions et
demi de personnes meurent chaque année
de la pollution de l'air urbain ce taux
augmente 4% dans le monde en seulement
cinq ans il est dû pour une grande
partie aux émissions de substances
polluantes que provoque nos activités
l'industrie chauffage au fuel ou encore
les transports sont les principaux
responsables des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais aussi de particules
fines et d'oxydés d'azoté à ce problème
majeur de santé publique s'ajoute un
coût important pour notre économie
évaluée toujours par l' ocde à 40
milliards d'euros par an pour la france
c'est plus précisément sur l'impact de
cette pollution et de ses émissions sur
la couche d'ozone qui protège notre
planète que je voudrais vous interroger
en effet cette pollution n'est pas qu'un
problème de centre-ville de circulation
des phrases structure domestique
l'atmosphère n'a pas de frontières et
donc ce problème est un problème
planétaire on sait que certaines
molécules sont responsables de la
disparition de l'ozone lorsqu'elles
pénètrent dans la stratosphère on sait
aussi que ces molécules chimiques que
les activités humaines ont introduites
persiste longtemps face à ce phénomène
d'une extrême gravité et les pays
industralisés ont adopté un protocole de
montréal en 1987 qui prévoyait une
réduction drastique et je pense que le
résultat est positif donc ma question
monsieur le ministre c'est donc de
savoir si au cours de la conférence de
paris sur le climat en 2015 est ce que
ce problème de la protection de
l'atmosphère sera qui est un sujet
planétaire pourra être abordée je crois
que c'est une opportunité qu'il ne faut
pas laisser passer et donc je vous
interroge très précisément sur cette
problème monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député votre question est toute à huy je
m'excuse et moi
vous avez raison j'ai passé la nuit
alors maintenant je suis un peu dans
pavlovien monsieur le sénateur donc je
vous remercie pour votre question qui
est tout à fait essentiel vous avez
tracée la perspective de la coop 21 qui
se tiendra à paris l'année prochaine
et vous avez raison de souligner à la
fois l'importance pour notre pays est
également l'aspect mondial de cette
question et le fait que nous sommes tous
impliqués la protection de la couche
d'ozone est donc un enjeu majeur pour
lequel la france est résolument engagée
et de ce point de vue trois mesures
concrètes aujourd'hui sont lancés au
niveau européen la france soutient le
nouveau règlement récemment adopté qui
prévoit une réduction de 79 % des
quantités diderot frio au carbone hfc
autorisés d'ici 2037 une des composantes
avec évidemment le co2 qui joue sur la
cause aux jeunes au niveau international
le protocole de montréal est en cours de
révision la france défend
l'élargissement donc de ce protocole osé
hfc dans cette négociation nous agissons
au côté des etats-unis et de la chine
pour une fois ce qui me permet de dire
aujourd'hui que cette position
ambitieuse a de grandes chances d'être
enfin le projet de loi programmation
pour un nouveau modèle énergétique
français contient un titre spécifique
qui traite des cas l'idée question de
qualité de l'air et des transports donc
une disposition instaurant particulier
un plan national de réduction des
émissions de polluants atmosphériques
qui fixera polluants par polluants les
objectifs de réduction à différents
horizons ces objets qui sont repris dans
des plans climat air énergie
territoriaux dont l'élaboration sera
confiée aux intercommunalités de
l'international au local le gouvernement
est donc pleinement mobilisée pour mieux
protéger la couche d'ozone et j'aurai
l'occasion aussi de revenir sur les
implications sur la santé de ces
questions ce que nous avons fait ce que
nous n'avons pas encore fait pour
préciser la position du gouvernement
merci monsieur raymond vall jeu mais
nice où vous remercie de votre
réponse et j'espère donc que cette
question qui me paraît fondamental sera
inscrite donc à la cover merci merci
l'après-vol à roger karoutchi pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président à monsieur le
ministre ma question concerne la
circulation alternée ou plus exactement
lorsqu'il y à des pics de pollution dans
les grandes villes notamment en ile de
france
l'utilisation par le gouvernement de ce
système dit de circulation alternée pour
soi-disant réduire la pollution on a eu
la question le 17 mars dernier le
gouvernement a hésité plusieurs jours
avant de le mettre en application et
stupidité si je puis dire du système le
gouvernement a décidé de le mettre en
application un moment où justement le
niveau de pollution baissé donc nous
avons passé plusieurs jours avec un
niveau de particules fines extrêmement
élevé et ce année ça n'a pas eu de en
réalité de conséquences positives que de
faire la circulation alternée je précise
d'ailleurs que
airparif continue d'affirmer que ça
n'est pas un bon système parce qu'en
réalité faire circuler les voitures un
père et voiture perd mais ne pas
distinguer entre les véhicules polluants
et les véhicules nettement moins
polluants parce que plus moderne etc ça
n'est pas une bonne solution alors
madame bateau avait dit fin 2012 qu on
supprimait les a pas qu'en supprimé
l'ensemble ces zones qui avaient quand
même l' avantage de faire la distinction
entre les véhicules polluants et les
autres d'autres capitales ont pris
d'autres systèmes péage urbain
circulation fermés dans les
centres-villes et c'est à ce qui n'est
pas l'objectif que nous recherchons mais
monsieur le ministre qu'est ce que vous
envisagez de faire d'abord par rapport
aux appâts
deuxième élément est ce que vous
considérez que la circulation alternée
c'est la bonne solution troisième éloize
que vous réfléchissez ce que le
gouvernement réfléchit à une solution
qui serait plus l équilibre et qui
ferait la distinction par rapport aux
véhicules polluants et aux véhicules
plus moderne n'étant pas polluant et
pouvoir circuler de manière continue
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le présent sur le
sénateur le président on est tous
président
jeu je trouve votre question
effectivement très intéressante et très
bien posé vous signaler l'importance
pour la connaissance des problèmes que
nous avons à traiter de la situation
d'airparif auquel évidemment je crois
que par ailleurs vous êtes attaché en
tant que membre d'une collectivité
territoriale qui aura aussi à donner les
moyens à airparif de continuer j'imagine
que vous serez engagé dans cette
dimension mais vous nous posez des
questions je pense que la circulation
alternée je pense que vous traitez un
peu vite les effets qu'elle a pu avoir
lorsqu'elle a été mis en place ces
derniers mois contrairement à ce que
vous pensez elle a sans doute accéléré
un mouvement de retour à la normale
peut-être et c'est une des suggestions
sur lesquels nous travaillons
elle aurait dû intervenir d'une façon
plus préventive que simplement j'allais
dire curatives mais on doit pouvoir
réfléchir à avoir une intervention plus
directe sur ce type de questions de
façon à faire en sorte que nous nous
retrouvions pas avec ses pics mais que
nous puissions les prévenir enfin vous
m'interrogez sur la question des appâts
malheureusement les appâts ce n'est pas
le gouvernement qui a renoncé c'est le
fait que cette méthode
absolument pas abouti et le gouvernement
n'a pu que constater le fait que les
appâts ne fonctionnait pas parce que
la plupart des collectivités
territoriales et celle un certain nombre
d'entre elles
vous les connaissez bien monsieur le
sénateur n'ont pas voulu jouer ce jeu
peut-être pour des raisons que je n'ai
pas à juger mais en tout cas elle ne
sont pas rentrés dans cette dimension
enfin vous nous posez donc je pense que
la circulation alternée tant qu'on n'a
pas opérer la transition massive de
notre parc automobile et de ce point de
vue est sans doute aussi réduit la part
de l'automobile globalement dans nos
déplacements et de ce point de vue je
n'entends pas toujours du côté de ce
côté-ci de l'assemblée
et du sénat tous les éléments qui
concourent à opérer cette limitation du
trafic automobile mais en tout état de
cause cette transition du parc
automobile vers des éléments non
polluant n'a pas encore obtenu
évidemment toutes les objectifs que nous
devrions nous fixer donc je pense pour
me résumer il faut prendre cette mesure
de gestion alternée pendant le temps que
nous opérons pour faire cette transition
globale de maximo ni sur karoutchi ou
très brièvement puis je pense que les a
pas on les a pas laissés vivre en vrai
bien des décrets n'ont pas été pris donc
c'était un peu compliqué pour les
collectivités de réagir et il faudrait
avoir de ce côté là une vision de la
part de l'état qui soit un peu plus un
peu plus complète et un peu plus
synthétique puis juste un mot monsieur
le ministre puisque vous dites que de ce
côté-là de l'hémicycle vous trouvez
qu'on ne vous dit pas suffisamment de
choses sur le trafic routier je vais
vous dire très sincèrement je suis pour
la limitation la réduction de la
circulation automobile en ile de france
quand on aura des transports publics
dignes de ce nom
bien la parole est à chantal jouanno
pour le groupe
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ça a été dit sur l'ensemble des
bons jusqu'à présent la question de la
qualité de l'air et le mal de ce siècle
c'est un problème social puisque c'est
une pollution particulièrement
inégalitaire c'est un problème
économique le président valls a rappelé
les chiffres du coût pour la nation et
c'est un problème sanitaire je dois
quand même rappeler qu'en 2030 environ
50% de la population française sera
touchée par des problèmes respiratoires
ou d'allergie donc c'est une question de
santé publique mais malheureusement la
loi santé publique est une arlésienne et
nous pouvons agir en attendant cette loi
assez mystérieuse on pouvant agir en
reprenant une disposition qui avait été
votée dans le cadre du grenelle à savoir
la généralisation des conseillers en
environnement intérieur c'est une à une
initiative alsacienne qui marche très
très bien qui permet pour les personnes
les plus touchées par des allergies
d'avoir des mesures préventives à leur
domicile donc où on s'aime où en
sommes-nous et de l'expérimentation et
de la généralisation deuxième mesure
préventive là aussi qui avait été
discutée dans le cadre du grenelle la
généralisation des mesures de pollution
de l'air dans les établissements
accueillant des publics sensibles on
avait lancé d'ailleurs la première
initiative à paris dans une école du 14e
arrondissement
mais au delà des mesures préventives ya
des mesures structurelles à prendre des
mesures structurelles qui vont bien
évidemment posé sur la fiscalité
aujourd'hui on a une fiscalité qui est
plutôt punitives à l'égard de l'ensemble
des français pour favoriser quelques
intérêts particuliers
or ça fait à peu près deux ans et demi
que avec beaucoup de constance j'essaye
de déposer un amendement pour
rééquilibrer la fiscalité entre le
diesel et l'essence sur dix ans en
baissant les taxes sur l'essence et en
augmentant celle sur le diesel et on me
renvoie systématiquement à un projet loi
sur la fiscalité écologique qui est très
attendue mais si j'ai bien compris qui
est totalement enterrée donc monsieur le
ministre est ce que vous allez changer
d'avis est ce que vous allez suivre les
recommandations du rapport pisani-ferry
page 123 qui recommande justement sur
dix ans de baisser les aides
dommageables à l'environnement et
d'augmenter la fiscalité écologique
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président merci madame
sénatrice votre engagement sur ces
questions est connue et je ne reprendrai
pas un certain nombre d'éléments de
réponse que j'ai déjà donné sur les
questions de fiscalité vous savez que
nous allons mettre en place une
fiscalité
sur
l'énergie qui va amener à ce qu'il y ait
qu elle pèse dans les années qui
viennent plus sûres évidemment les
énergies fossiles et singulièrement sur
le diesel que les taxations et
existantes aujourd'hui faisant une
différenciation entre le diesel et les
autres formes d'énergies fossiles
néanmoins nous avons tous conscience que
l'impératif de santé publique que vous
énoncez
peut-être nos concitoyens nous mêmes je
reviens aussi à ce que disait le
sénateur karoutchi précédemment je n'ai
pas l'impression qu'il y ait eu une
mobilisation suffisante j'entends quand
on nous parle des transports collectifs
évidemment mais vous savez très bien sûr
le sénateur vous le savez très bien que
ce n'est pas simplement les transports
collectifs qui peuvent répondre à la
demande de transport il ya donc toutes
les formes alternatives de transport il
ya les questions d'aménagement qui font
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de nos
concitoyens notamment en ile-de-france
sont obligés de faire des trajets
considérable parce que pour l'essentiel
les logements sont à l'aise et les
bureaux et les activités sont à l'ouest
oui mais donc il y à des problèmes
globaux de la société et vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir manas sénatrice sur
le fait que toutes ces questions sont
des problèmes qui sont posés
globalement et qu'ils seront d'ailleurs
en partie traités dans la loi de
transition énergétique et s'agissant
plus spécifiquement
des modes de transport nous avons pris
du retard parce que ici ou là il n'y a
pas eu la prise de conscience par
exemple sur les véhicules électriques
je rappelle que y compris des gens très
attaché à l'écologie ont combattu
pendant des années pour des raisons
idéologiques
la perspective d'avoir des véhicules
électriques un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui ont été prises par des
collectivités territoriales par exemple
la ville de paris sur autolib ont
largement été combattu ici ou là pour
des raisons idéologiques de façon très
importante donc je pense que prenions
conscience ensemble de la réalité et des
efforts que nous devons ensemble
accomplir mais je pense qu'il serait
assez illégitime de faire poser sur
cette majorité la seule responsabilité
d'une situation qui vient ici madame
jouanno
ce ministre j'ai pas eu mes réponses
peut-être que si madame la ministre
avait été là elle aurait pu répéter
qu'elle ne veut pas de modification de
la fiscalité mais peu importe
le problème reste entier alors à propos
du véhicule électrique j'en profite
puisque j'ai la parole monsieur le
président du sénat s'il y avait des
prises électriques qui fonctionnent et
accessible au sénat ce serait formidable
pour les véhicules électriques merci je
vais essayer d'aider ce soir madame la
sénatrice la parole est à ou
d'interviews pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur ministre chers
collègues à mon tour en 2012
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
confirmé que les fumées émises par les
moteurs diesel était bien des agents
cancérogènes leur impact sur la santé
humaine est donc avérée notamment à
cause des particules fines mais aussi
des oxydes d'azoté elles contiennent les
résultats des analyses les plus récentes
attestent que la mortalité non
accidentels journalières augmente en
fonction des concentrations plus ou
moins forte de ces particules fines en
ile de france tout particulièrement les
périodes de forte concentration sa
compagne l'augmentation de 2 à 7 % des
passages aux urgences d'enfants pour des
problèmes respiratoires
si les sources de ces pollutions peuvent
être multiples et si en france les
émissions sont majoritairement due au
chauffage des résidences à l'activité
industrielle et tertiaire le secteur des
transports routiers y contribue pour une
part conséquente évaluée à près de 20%
or malgré un fort recul des ventes en
2013 les véhicules fonctionnant au
gazole représente est encore en france
plus de 60 % du parc automobile total et
environ 67 % des ventes de nouveaux
véhicules
grâce aux restrictions réglementaires
cependant les émissions des particules
fines ont néanmoins diminué de près de
30 % entre 2000 et 2011 pour passer de
350 milles à 250 milles tonnes cette
évolution devrait encore être amplifiée
par la mise en oeuvre du plan d'urgence
pour la qualité de l'air qui a débuté en
avril 2013 cependant il conviendrait
peut-être monsieur le ministre d'aller
plus loin et d'encourager le changement
des habitudes de nos concitoyens sans
toutefois bien sûr porter atteinte
brutalement à un secteur économique
souvent en difficulté
c'est un enjeu à la fois économique et
une exigence de service public
c'est pourquoi alors que le dispositif
du bonus malus écologique ne concernent
aujourd'hui que les émissions de co2 je
vous demande monsieur le ministre comme
ma collègue madame archambault s'il
n'est pas possible de constituer un
outil intéressant à travers ce bonus
malus et de l'étendre à d'autres pôles
eu d'autres polluants notamment ces
particules merci monsieur jean marie le
guen
si monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
merci de votre question qui rappellent
malgré les interpellations précédente
qui rappelle déjà le chemin qui a été
parcouru
c'est à dire que même si notre pays a eu
un certain retard en la matière
constatant le puisque nous avons sans
doute des chiffres notamment dans nos
grandes agglomérations qui sont parmi
les plus mauvais au plan européen
nous avons un peu progressé et nous
avons progressé notamment en raison des
effets qui ont été faits sur plutôt
j'allais dire plus que sur les
transports mais plutôt sur l'industrie
et j'espère que ceci n'est pas liée à
une certaine forme aussi
de désindustrialisation qui peut exister
dans notre pays mais donc nous avons
progressé et donc il est possible de
continuer à progresser vous avez rappelé
à juste titre le plan
protection de l'air et qui est un
élément tout à fait important et vous
insistez à votre tour à juste titre sur
la mutation qui est possible de notre
parc de voitures diesel vous insistez et
vous avez raison sur les questions de
fiscalité j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
répondre à un autre votre collègue
archimbaud que ces questions
seront reçus avec une attention
particulière par le gouvernement et
notamment je l'espère dans la loi de
finances de l'année prochaine en
rappelant d'ailleurs combien il fallait
être attentive aussi à la situation de
nos concitoyens qui ont été qui sont
engagés sur une motorisation diesel et
sur la nécessité sans doute de
différencier les zones de notre
territoire puisque les conséquences ne
sont pas les mêmes donc nous continuons
à travailler dans cette direction et en
travaillant à des offres alternatives
parmi ces offres alternatives encore une
fois l'offre de véhicules hybrides eu en
tout cas de véhicules électriques est
sans doute une piste sur laquelle nous
devons tous travailler d'une façon plus
volontariste et sans a priori comme
peut-être nous verrons trophée par le
passé
merci madame aux interviews merci
monsieur le président je voulais vous
remercier monsieur le ministre pour
votre réponse qui rejoignent le rapport
que j'ai eu l'honneur de présenter à ma
commission sur ce même sujet je crois
qu'il ya donc est en effet une réelle
nécessité non seulement de faire
progresser les évolutions techniques
pour les véhicules diesel mais même dans
d'autres véhicules puisque je crois que
les dernières nouveautés pour les
véhicules essence se font qu'on a aussi
malheureusement ces particules fines qui
ressurgissent mais également de
favoriser vous l'avez dit le
développement de véhicules réellement
plus propre et pourquoi pas ces
véhicules électriques pour permettre à
nos concitoyens surtout d'y accéder plus
facilement
merci la parlotte à présent évoluer dit
et pour le groupe crc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues selon la
dernière étude sur la qualité de l'air
publié par l'agencé européenne pour
l'environnement 90% des citadins de
l'union européenne sont exposés à l'un
des polluants atmosphériques les plus
nocifs et à des niveaux jugés dangereux
pour la santé par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé les transports
l'industrie l'agriculture et les
habitations contribuent à la pollution
de l'air en europe malgré la diminution
des rejets et la baisse de la
concentration de certains polluants
atmosphériques au cours des dernières
décennies on a évoqué quelques pistes
l'impact sanitaire de la pollution reste
très préoccupant
deux polluants en particulier les
particules fines est l'ozone au niveau
du sol sont pointés du doigt la
pollution atmosphérique n'est pas un
fléau urbain certaines zones rurales
présentant aussi des niveaux et blé et
levé les zones autour des axes routiers
sans oublier le transport aérien
chaque année en france les particules
fines seraient responsables de plus de
40 mille morts soit dix fois plus que le
nombre de morts accidentelles sur la
route et on y voit pas la même
mobilisation alors que cette question de
santé publique appellent des mesures
urgentes et un effort collectif
nous en sommes encore à chercher des
solutions individuelles les transports
sont un des secteurs qui devraient
illustrer cette démarche collective pour
lutter contre ce fléau avec pour
objectif le renforcement des transports
alternatifs à la route sur l'ensemble du
territoire cela nécessite des moyens
financiers importants y compris en
direction des collectivités
territoriales on sait que l' agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport de france manque de moyens
pour soutenir les projets des
collectivités
on sait aujourd'hui que le ph de transit
annoncé ne généra que 500 millions
d'euros annuels pouvez vous monsieur le
ministre nous éclairer sur les autres
pistes de financement pour soutenir les
projets des transports collectifs en
site propre des collectivités
territoriales je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je vous remercie de votre
question vous insister sur un point
particulier dans notre débat et qui est
très important s'agissant notamment des
transports collectifs en site propre
les ressources de l'actif vous en avait
parlé doivent être amendées pour venir
compléter l'apport du nouveau péage de
transit qui sera mis en place début 2015
et qui permettra ainsi à l'état de
porter une politique des transports
cohérente avec les enjeux du
développement durable avec le
développement d'une offre de transport
alternatives à la roue c'est donc le
financement du troisième appel à projets
des transports en site propre qui
s'inscrit pleinement dans ces
orientations le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé sur le sujet les
discussions se tiennent au plus haut
niveau entre le premier ministre le
ministre de l'écologie et des finances
pour définir les solutions à mettre en
oeuvre je témoigne de ça pour montrer
l'importance que nous apportons à ce
sujet notamment dans le cadre des
arbitrages en cours de préparation du
budget triennal 2015-2017 l'appel à
projets transports collectifs et
mobilité durable lancé le 7 mai 2013
avait été annoncé avec une enveloppe de
450 millions d'euros au 15 septembre
dernier 120 aussi ont été déposés les
résultats ne sont pas encore annoncés
c'est donc au vu de la loi de finances
2015 et du trial 2015-2017 que les
décisions seront prises avec un retour
en direction des collectivités locales
concernées mais en tout état de cause je
vous confirme que le gouvernement
tiendra en la matière tout à fait
précisément ses engagements merci madame
evelyne didier
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
réponses nous en acceptons longueur ne
nous examinerons attentivement la le
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
et les mesures que vous avez indiquée
pour autant je voudrais mettre en garde
le gouvernement sur la question du
renvoi systématique à des solutions
individuelles bien entendu le
comportement de nos concitoyens est
important il faudra à pouvoir et je
pense que les bonus sont beaucoup plus
efficaces que les malus en l'occurrence
donc inciter les particuliers mais la
réponse globalement et bien du niveau
collectif et d'une nouvelle ère
gouvernementale je crois qu'il faut
faire attention de ne pas toujours
envoyer sur les individus très bien la
parole était alain fouché pour le groupe
un peu
le président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais porter à votre attention sur
les travaux en cours à l'organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale oaci
qui vise à définir au niveau mondial un
système de compensation des émissions
carbone émise par l'aviation ce futur
système devraient être adoptées en 2016
pour une mise en place en 2020 en
attendant sa mise en place c'est le
système de le ts système d'échangé de
quotas d'émissions qui fonctionne pour
l'europe
celui-ci maintenu uniquement sur le
périmètre des vols intra européens
jusqu'en 2016 bénéficiera d'une
possibilité de prolongation jusqu'en
2020 afin d'anticiper la mise en place
du système mondial en tout état de cause
à partir de 2020 un système mondial basé
sur le marché du carbone prévoir à la
compensation de toutes les émissions de
co2 au dessus du niveau atteint en 2020
cependant pour qu'il soit efficace il
faut l'accord des pays émergents il est
donc indispensable
de prendre en compte les compagnies de
ces pays s'il est pour l'instant
difficile de spéculer monsieur le
ministre sur le compte sur les
conclusions des négociations pour
lesquelles il existe un vrai risque de
distorsion de concurrence entre les
compagnies européennes et celles des
pays émergents je souhaite interroger le
gouvernement sur les suites qu'il compte
donner au système européen ets les
compagnies européennes et françaises
sont inquiètes de la disparition à
l'horizon 2016 du périmètre actuel de le
ts qui écarte les vols transcontinentaux
peuvent-elles compter sur le soutien du
gouvernement français en ce qui concerne
le maintien de ce périmètre et sur la
limitation de ce système aux seuls vols
intra européens
je vous remercie de votre réponse merci
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur jean merci pour votre question
vous êtes un peu un spécialiste de ce
sujet qui est un sujet important dans
ses dimensions environnementales mais
aussi dans ses dimensions de commerce
internationale et singulièrement
d'attractivité de compétitivité de notre
économie donc une fois encore nous
sommes partagés entre la nécessité de
faire avancer la prise de conscience
internationale et donc de limiter
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre et en
même temps la nécessité de composer avec
une réalité internationale qu'il ne peut
pas s'auto décidé simplement au plan
européen
donc je veux évidemment après vous
rappeler que le secteur aérien doit
participer activement à ses efforts de
réduction que le fameux système de le ts
les systèmes d'échangé de quotas
d'émissions fonctionne actuellement
appelle une solution à l'échelle
mondiale comme vous l'avez souligné dans
le cadre de l'oaci l'organisation de
l'action civile internationale donc
effectivement là pour avancer l'europe a
décidé de l'appliquer dans un premier
temps aux vols intra communautaires
quelle que soit la compagnie il faut
désormais c'est exact ce système soit
étendu à l'échelle mondiale sachez que
la france est pleinement mobilisé
engagés dans ces négociations qui sont
amenés au sein de l'oaci pour y parvenir
nous sommes optimistes dans la mesure où
le principe a été acté lors de la
dernière assemblée générale de l'oaci
qui s'est tenue à l'automne dernier là
encore la perspective de la coop 21 qui
se tiendra à la fin de l'année 2015 peut
nous essayer de nous dégager une prise
de conscience internationale qui ne
laisse indifférent aucun secteur des
transports aucun secteur de notre
économie avec une prise de conscience
internationale et par secteur espérons
donc les capacités de conviction de la
france tantôt plan intra européen qu'au
plan extra européens arrivera à vous
donner satisfaction et à concilier les
impératifs d'attractivité les impératifs
de responsabilité en matière
d'environnement internationale merci
alain fouché
de votre réponse qui me satisfait je
sais que vous êtes très attentifs et
vous et vous serez très attentifs parce
que c'est très important pour la planète
merci beaucoup merci la parole est à
présent à delphine bataille pour le
groupe socialiste merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues en octobre dernier
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
classé la pollution de l'air qui nous
entourent dans la catégorie des
cancérigènes certains pour l'homme des
études confirment aujourd'hui qu'il
s'agit du principal risque
environnemental dans le monde et indique
que sept millions de personnes sont
décédés prématurément l'année dernière
du fait de l'exposition à la pollution
de l'air d'après le ms les risques à
l'intérieur des locaux comme à
l'extérieur sont désormais important en
ce qui concerne notamment les
cardiopathies et les accidents
vasculaires pour cette pollution qui a
un effet direct sur l'environnement et
sur la santé les principales sources de
polluants sont comme pour les gaz à
effet de serre les installations
industrielles les équipements de
chauffage de l'agriculture et les
transports notamment toutefois la france
figure derrière la suède au deuxième
rang européen en ce qui concerne les
pays dont l'air est le moins toxiques en
co2 car l'énergie nucléaire notamment
contribuer contrairement aux énergies
fossiles à limiter les rejets dans
l'atmosphère et à préserver ainsi la
qualité de notre ère il n'en demeure pas
moins que le niveau de pollution reste
important est que nous connaîtrons
encore de graves pics de pollution
atmosphérique dans le nord la ville de
douai arrive au classement de l'om s
parmi l'une des villes les plus polluées
de france bien que les résultats de ce
classement soit à relativiser la lutte
contre la pollution atmosphérique
représente un véritable enjeu sanitaire
pour le département et pour toute la
région qui s'est construite
historiquement autour d'une industries
énergivores
les décideurs et les acteurs sont
aujourd'hui mobilisées pour promouvoir
une économie décarbonée à travers de
nombreux projets qui ont surtout dans
l'immédiat besoins de financement et
l'apport de l'état reste ainsi essentiel
pour acquis panier nos territoires je
souhaite savoir monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures le gouvernement compte
prendre dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique pour
accompagner et soutenir nos territoires
dans leurs actions qui contribuent à
répondre à ces enjeux essentiels de
santé publique je vous remercie
merci
monsieur le guen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice votre question me permettra de
répondre très précisément sur les
avancées contenues aujourd'hui dans la
loi de programmation pour un nouveau
modèle énergétique français
qui je crois va répondre pour
l'essentiel à votre question et enfin
pour beaucoup à votre question pas dans
sa totalité malheureusement parce que
les questions vous posiez sont tellement
importantes qu'une seule luan il suffira
pas mais un dea en tout cas nous voulons
inscrire la france dans un développement
peu émetteur de gaz à effet de serre et
donc cette loi fixera pour période de
cinq ans des objectifs nationaux de
réduction des émissions de polluants
atmosphériques ces objectifs seront
déclinés dans des actions
opérationnelles secteur par secteur
industrie transport résidentiel
agriculture le texte prévoit en outre
plusieurs mesures
la possibilité aux agglomérations qui le
souhaitent de restreindre la circulation
des véhicules les plus polluants je
réponds là ce cas rocci qu'il trouvera
sans aucun doute une raison de voter
pour le texte que nous proposerons
bientôt à votre assemblée il favorise le
développement de moyens de déplacement
moins émetteurs notamment le véhicule
électrique grâce au déploiement des
bornes de recharge c'était aussi une des
questions qui étaient posées par votre
assemblée y compris au sénat si j'ai
bien compris monsieur le président il
renforce les outils de planification
territoriale en faveur de la qualité de
l'air pour inscrire résolument les
collectivités dans la lutte contre la
pollution des règlements il impose enfin
aux chargeurs de grande distribution de
mettre en oeuvre des actions de
réduction des effets de serre nous
souhaitons également que les incitations
positives soient mises en place pour
faciliter le renouvellement des
véhicules ces fameux véhicules
électriques qui ont longtemps n'ont pas
trouvé tout le soutien qu'elles auraient
dû parmi les défenseurs de
heureusement ans notamment en faveur des
ménages modestes une prime à la
conversion des ailes les plus anciens
sera mise en place associée au bonus
électrique elle pourrait conduire à une
prime de 10 mille euros enfin pour
stimuler le marché des véhicules propres
les flottes de véhicules de l'état sont
renouvelés au moins pour moitié par des
véhicules écologiques
merci pour la réponse delphine bataille
merci monsieur ministre même si l'état
des lieux peut sembler parfois anxiogène
vous venez de montrer que le
gouvernement a véritablement pris en
compte la question de la santé publique
qui est d'ailleurs incontournable à un
moment où les médecins s'accordent à
dire que l'exposition aux poussières sur
de longues périodes à des concentrations
plus faibles est aussi préoccupante
voire plus qu'une exposition ponctuelle
à des concentrations élevées c'est
pourquoi la question des poussières en
suspension fait l'objet de nombreuses
études sanitaires et cette pollution en
particules fines nécessite donc la
mobilisation d'un maximum d'acteurs
parce que les valeurs réglementaires
sont régulièrement dépassés par exemple
en ce qui concerne la région nord pas de
calais les préfets de région présenté un
plan de protection de l'atmosphère dont
les actions s'inscrivent dans la durée
pour lutter contre la pollution de fond
et de nombreux partenaires sont
sollicités aux côtés des actions
régaliennes menée par l'état néanmoins
près de 90 % du budget de la mort est
consacré à la surveillance de
l'atmosphère inscrite dans les textes
réglementaires et il semble aujourd'hui
nécessaire de développer des actions
nouvelles soutenu par les collectivités
locales autour des enjeux régionaux et
territoriaux cheveux mais non merci la
parole est à présent hélène conway
mouret pour le groupe socialiste merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crains
que vous avez déjà répondu partiellement
à la question que je m'apprête à poser
sur la place réservée à la pollution
atmosphérique
lors de la conférence climat qui se
tiendra à paris en décembre 2015 en
effet la france accueillera la grande
conférence des nations unies sur le
climat conférence
mines ayant appelé coop 21 à cette
occasion ce seront plus de 25 mille
délégués venus du monde entier qui se
pencheront sur les questions relatives à
l'avenir de notre planète nous sommes
tous concernés par le dérèglement
climatique et en particulier par
l'impact de la pollution sur la santé
comme cela a été rappelé par un certain
nombre de mes collègues
chaque année plus de quarante deux mille
français meurent prématurément en raison
de la pollution de l'air donc sur les
bases de ces chiffres inquiétants ne
serait-il pas judicieux d'adopter
rapidement des plans de protection de
l'atmosphère
la reconquête de la qualité de l'air
constituent un enjeu sanitaire majeur et
justifie me semble-t-il la mobilisation
de tous les acteurs concernés et je
pense que nous le sommes tous la
pollution atmosphérique doit avoir toute
sa place lors de cette conférence
mondiale de 2015 la france la prépare
activement des discussions sont engagées
et les négociations ont commencé la
france déploie d'intenses efforts
diplomatiques pour qu'un accord
ambitieux soit finalisée alors monsieur
le ministre pouvez vous nous indiquer
comment la france entend peser sur les
orientations relatives à la pollution
atmosphérique lors de la conférence
climat et la place qui lui sera réservé
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice votre question est sans doute
celle qui permet de mettre en place dans
un cadre stratégique
toutes les questions qui nous ont été
posées à juste titre aujourd'hui en
effet nous savons que la france peut
avoir une action résolue elle peut
avancer par exemple dans la pollution
atmosphérique à l'intérieur de ces
villes mais fondamentalement elle ne
peut pas traiter globalement la
problématique de l'effet de serre à la
fois parce que elle seule ne serait pas
capable de changer le destin du monde et
donc des conséquences du réchauffement
climatique
et deuxièmement parce que en étant trop
volontariste dégagé par rapport à la
concurrence internationale elle se
verrait très lourdement pénalisées
notamment en matière industrielle et
donc
là la perspective qui a été dressé par
le président de la république sur cette
fameuse comme 21 qui essaye de
relever le défi de l'échec de copenhague
est de faire en sorte que nous arrivions
à avoir une politique à faire converger
des politiques internationales vers ces
objectifs est quelque chose de tout à
fait essentiel alors vous le savez la
méthode qui a été adoptée sera sans
doute une méthode plus souple plus
pragmatique que celle qui avait été
adoptée par copenhague avec l'idée
d'arriver sur des critères qui
correspondent à l'égalité pour tout le
monde et dans tous les secteurs et vous
savez que la dynamique diplomatique qui
a été mise en oeuvre à la fois par la
france qui est le principal organisateur
de cette conférence internationale mais
aussi par tous les participants je veux
dire la société civile telle qu'elle est
organisée autour de cette question au
plan international permet de faire
avancer les dossiers à la fois par
grandes branches industrielles par
grandes thématiques et par grand
continent en partant à chaque fois de
l'endroit où nous sommes pour faire un
saut de progression et l'engagement
politique du président et du
gouvernement est total dans cette
affaire nous espérons que nous pourrons
aboutir enfin à des résultats
significatifs qui nous permettront
d'inverser le risque de réchauffement
climatique tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
programmé avec une connaissance
scientifique qui est maintenant assez
grande merci monsieur le ministre madame
qu'on aimerait
dire monsieur le ministre que je me
réjouis de la volonté politique qui
anime le gouvernement qui nous semble
aujourd'hui être essentiel non seulement
à la réussite de la conférence mais
aussi je pense pour le bien-être futur
de nous tous
merci mes chers collègues je vais à
présent passer la parole à monsieur
philippe marie dit le président marigny
pour en rappeler le règlement
merci beaucoup monsieur le président du
sénat ce rappel au règlement se fonde
sur l'article 29 bis dudit règlement qui
concerne l'organisation de nos travaux
et les missions dévolues à notre
conférence des présidents il s'agit
comme on l'aura compris des conditions
d'examen de la loi portant réforme
territoriale comme chacun le sait une
commission spéciale a été constituée
elle a eu très peu de temps pour
travailler
elle n'a pas pu adopter de rapport à ma
connaissance
d'où l'insatisfaction qui s'exprime au
sein de plusieurs de nos groupes et qui
les conduisent pas solliciter de votre
part monsieur le président une réunion
de la conférence des présidents pour
aménager l'ordre du jour de telle sorte
que les études d'impact indispensable
sur le fait par exemple dans le domaine
budgétaire et j'en terminerai par là
puisque le chiffrage des bénéfices à
attendre de ces regroupements a été
évaluée à des montants très divers si
l'on en croit le secrétaire d'état notre
ancien collègue andré vallini on a
entendu
5,12 plus tard et tout cela semble-t-il
devrait nécessiter et des études plus
approfondies de telle sorte que le sénat
puisse délibérer en première lecture
dans la sérénité
si monsieur le président je viens de
vous entendre et j'étais également saisi
par les groupes ctrc ump src j'ai donc
décidé de convoquer la confiance je sers
c'est ump et rdse pardon j'ai donc
décidé de convoquer la conférence des
présidents aujourd'hui à 16h15 salle de
la commission de la culture la séance
est suspendue
voilà pour ces questions cribles
consacrée à la pollution de l'air un
sujet qui a été au coeur des
préoccupations mois de mars dernier
lorsque de nombreuses grandes villes
françaises ont été atteintes par des
pics de pollution aux particules fines à
19h ne manquez pas 24 heures sénat
présenté par delphine girard avec notre
dernier épisode consacré à la réforme
pénale très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires